[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et à toutes
gérard vous êtes là où je ne suis pas
grand chose j'ai une petite mise au
point à faire avant de vous présenter si
vous le voulez bien aussi nouveaux
candidats savaient que nous avons reçu
de très très nombreuses lettres de
téléspectateurs mécontents parce qu'ils
ont envoyé un truc et que ce truc est
présenté par une autre personne
alors nous en excusons bien sûr mais
nous vous rappelons que nous avons reçu
plusieurs plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de lettres dans lesquelles nous
retrouvons le même truc
il faut donc faire un choix est ce choix
bien nous l'avons confiée au hasard par
tirage au sort alors si vous voulez vous
voulez pas nous en vouloir je pense que
je n'ai rien oublié j'ai tout ira bien
vous pensiez chose très importante la
clé du mystère truc appartenant à
monsieur durand de la rochelle vos 900
francs ce soir est un tout nouveau truc
les noix magnétique 300 francs payet est
bien simple dames pour un monsieur que
je vous présente tout de suite madame
votre nom candidat numéro 1 heure de
crêpes une bonne candidate numéro 2 de
paris candidate numéro 3 le jeune
guillaume de paris candidate numéro 4
madame cousinié le péru ce jeudi d'un
numéro pardon sujet de bobigny est
candidate numéro six villes ans de
maison
le regardons ensemble la clé du mystère
truc un partenaire monsieur durand de la
rochelle
il vous ce soir 900 francs
[Musique]
lucien durand et représentant à la
rochelle nous a proposé un truc très
étrange une clé tient tout seul sur une
surface par cole pas de colle mais alors
comment faites vous savez monsieur majak
il ya un truc et c'est à vous de le
trouver
madame vasseur candidate numéro un une
question à poser à jerram je pensais en
frottant fortement et vivement la plaie
contre la paroi
d'où vous est venue cette idée
quand j'étais enfin prenez une pièce est
souvent s'amusait à frotter une pièce
sur le muc
il tenait à bon
je ne sais pas mais elle n'est pas n'a
pas une surface plate punisher madame je
vous en prie tenez voici la clé contre
le mur vous avez une paroi normal
essayez madame a peut-être un peu plus
fort
écoutez madame c'est vraiment une façon
de s'y prendre qui compte quand vous
étiez petit quand vous jouiez avec nick
clegg
eh bien madame vous avez bien fait de
vous en souvenir car là vous ne vous y
êtes peut-être mal pris vous êtes très
nerveuse et ça se voit madame les
projecteurs l'ambiance d'émotion mais
vous avez trouvé et gagner madame 900
france
rien que madame oui je crois que ça fait
très plaisir à nos amis qui sont dans la
salle car il vient de voir que c'est en
se rappelant un souvenir d'enfance elle
que cette pièce qui tenait monsieur
durand a compliqué le tour car avec une
pièce c'est plus facile qu'avec une clé
et il faut frotter mais vous allez voir
monsieur durand d'ailleurs vous
l'expliquez vous même et vous le faire
pour réussir ce truc
la clé n'est absolument pas truqué il
suffit simplement de prendre fortement
la clé et de la frottée sur le mur en
appuyant cette clé
si vous insistez et surtout qui vous
entraînez tiendra toute seule forme et
bien bravo madame non seulement vous
avez gagné le 100 francs mais en plus
vous gagnez le livre y'a un truc vous
regagnez votre place encore bravo bravo
bravo madame
oui oui vous restez là attention
et nous passons tout de suite à notre
deuxième truc les noix magnétique qui
lui vaut 300 francs aujourd'hui un truc
avec des noirs elles sont posées dans
une assiette et après les avoir remué un
petit moment on essaie un phénomène
magnétique et un an
je suis de monter très doucement les
mains et toutes les noix monte à celle
ci est mauvaise mais deux sont bonnes
etienne contre les doigts
mystérieusement
mais là aussi il ya un truc lequel
mademoiselle pape une question à poser à
gérard vous aimer les noix
allez-y une question est ce que les les
doigts sont mouillés avant que les
doigts sont mouillés avec quoi madame
avec de l'eau vraiment mouillé c'est à
dire ' avec de l'eau non non non non pas
mouiller avec de madame guillaume est ce
que vous faites une préparation avant
avec les noix c'est à dire vous les
ouvrez légèrement par le haut et quand
vous voulez placer tous vous appuyez vos
doigts et ça coince le bout des doigts
et vous remontez mais oui madame c'est
ça venait pas noir
mais vous en soir venez vous asseoir
près de moi madame mais dit non c'est
pas gentil pour les trois derniers
candidats ça parce que si la première
candidate se trouve le ton numéro un
vous vous trouvez le tour au numéro 2
mais les trois autres alors y
reviendrons en priorité leur reviendront
pour d'autres émissions
mais aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas de chance
des dents alors regardez malin vous
allez le faire vous même parce que vous
l'avez bien compris il faut quand même
nous le montrer c'est un tout qu'on a
choisi pour les enfants car beaucoup
d'enfants m'écrivent en me disant qu'ils
veulent et au sein comment me suis mal
amusé de la force dit le bien fort
madame qu'on vous entende attendait non
voilà regardez madame voyez là je presse
mettez votre doigt voilà on hache a
parlé c'est la mauvaise comme on le
disait voilà alesi appuyé montrer le
bien madame fait semblant
maintenant mettez vos mains au-dessus
dès demain fait le tour pour montrer à
nos amis comment il faut s'y prendre
qu'est-ce que vous expliquer non elle ne
précise pas sur l'autre celle de pour
une seule
vous dites voilà non non ne me dites pas
fait le tour vous montrez des noix que
vous essayez essayer de les soulever
ah bah non maintenant l'employé enfin on
a compris madame on la sait pas si vous
allez révolue encore une fois une
dernière fois je vous appuyez en fait à
deux normales je vais le faire tout seul
voilà on a bien écarté ça coince la peau
maintenant fait semblant de les manier
tiges et et vous soulevez dans les
immeubles hormis la maintiens tout seul
c'est formidable marché par la peau très
bien vous avez gagné ma vendre le livre
est venu vous dis un grand bravo
également
bravo madame vous avez gagné trois
enfants et à une prochaine émission bien
nous aurons de nouveaux trucs
l'un le bouchon s'évade appartenant
monsieur théo habitants grenoble il
faudra 300 francs ce nouveau truc et le
sucre désintégrer 300 francs également
également par contre au revoir et bonne
fin de soirée à paris dit théo et
comptable à grenoble elle nous présente
un truc il vous faut une carafe
contenant de l'eau un flotteur et une
aiguille fixé sur le bouchon à
l'intérieur de la carafe le bouchon va
se trouver prisonniers sur les 8 ou
plaçons le tout dans la carafe et nous
voyons que le bouchon est prisonnier sur
l'aiguillé il faut maintenant libéré le
bouchon s'en retirer la tige bien
entendu ni retourner le boca comment
faire il y a un truc à vous de le
trouver
[Musique]
un truc avec 3 sucre c3 sucre sont
placés dans la main gauche et maintenant
je retire l'un d'eux que je pose sur la
table il reste dessus
un simple mouvement comme cela sur les
doigts l'un des sucres a disparu et n'en
reste plus qu'un quel est le truc qui
permet cette désintégration
[Musique]